[Music]
all right
hey welcome to Uncle Tim's Farm
you're probably wondering what's going
on well
we're supposed to be getting a bunch of
rain and where these pigs have been
living
when that ground gets wet it is
impossible for me to get in there
it basically turns to just grease on the
surface
so I'm having to pull those pigs out of
there
for now well they're gonna be harvested
in just over a week
or actually yeah just over a week a week
from tomorrow
we're going to harvest them and so I
need to get them out of there because we
have we're expecting a bunch of rain the
next couple nights and then again all
next week it's supposed to rain so that
ground would just be way too wet for me
to get in there and get hooked up to
that trailer
so I went ahead and pulled them out
today and they're just gonna
go ahead and live in that trailer for
the next week
and I'll go ahead and add some more
straw in there they've had quite a bit
of straw put in a water bucket and a
feed tub
and that's just where they'll live for
the next week
they've already basically been spending
90 percent of their time in there they
go in there for shelter they sleep in
there
so it's not going to be that drastic of
a change for them the only thing is is
they won't have access to the pond you
know get out and roam around to go down
to the pond but
they'll be fine for the next week and
this way I am sure that I have them out
of there so that we can Harvest them
next week
foreign
[Music]
ah
good evening
foreign
[Music]
uh-huh
well the pigs are all moved and settled
in
got their food and water for them
their food tub
water bucket
and lots of straw
so they should be set for the next week
in here should keep them nice and
comfortable
and I don't have to worry about not
being able to get into that
pasture to be able to
get them out of there
and it's looking like there
nice and big and ready to be harvested
thanks for watching and don't forget to
like subscribe share do all that good
stuff help support the channel
and I will see you next time thanks bye
[Music]